alright so we're sitting in the back of
air streams latest and greatest
invention which is instead of a trailer
it's a fully functional separate tour
event right it's a dodge sprinter that
it's been basically gutted from the
inside and air streams come in and
retrofitted the entire interior with all
these cool experiments so the shower the
TV the kitchen the bed mini fridge this
is a half-time oven so basically half
the time it can be a standard microwave
or it can turn into a conventional oven
the dining room table here we have the
combination of a shower and bathroom the
outside of the shower actually opens up
a little bit and just like so so give
you a little bit extra room they're kind
of like move around and shower in here
this is like the electrical lamebrain
over here so this is here's the tank
test so here's our black water that
would be the superb water that would be
the pooper yeah here's the grey water
that would be from the sink over here
we've got the battery voltage so here's
what we're running it which is 13-point
5655 bolts let's say we're driving down
the road we want to watch television or
I guess I want to watch television when
Danny's driving me down the road will
pop it to auto invert right and then you
just run off that so this thing's
awesome Danny but like really what are
we gonna do with it dude let's take it
to LA
so here we are we just started on our
journey down the 101 Stephens driving
right now and frankly he's scaring me
mad but the fact that I was kind of late
the only reason to come here is to take
a piss because the bathroom is amazing
yeah so here we are on the madonna inn
because even had to take a pee and we're
in quite pot way with the world's
weirdest journal the kid does that when
it flexes anna now we're on the road at
the side of a highway and we add we can
figure out where the gas tank is so none
of these are a gas heading the fuel
filler cap is next to the driver's door
as I told you you can only open the fuel
filler flap where the driver's door is
open about this oh oh thank you right
now awesome I could really good right
now we're smart about this is look at
the guests who that's that's a good 15
feet right there so now we're here
running the generator it's like 1130 and
as quiet as we thought the generator was
i'm pretty sure that all the old people
or living in this septic mess that is
the beach outside cuz literally it
smells like septic tank I'm pretty it
does really cool out here smells like
who I'm pretty sure that they're all
going to come in knocking like knocking
out our window to better in it even and
I are having a delicious dinner of a why
I bought this this is apparently the
bomb so this is the man so stoked about
that and this is my dinner this this
burrito is about as cold as penguin
pecker where words is waiting for our
delicious meal to cook and it's it's
kind of not right now it's kind of a
worst dinner morning Danny mornings
hidden that was an awkward evening
there's now this ticket over here there
is so this has been Steven making our
get away from the campground look we
have just illegally camped at the
suckers fast
like a block or two away from where we
camped last night that's right where
were we yeah crashed really yeah I guess
where we decided to park our home we got
some instant coffee a lot of eggs we
have a lot of salsa we have some
tortillas yeah so you know we're gonna
make you wear those on shuttles so
steven has been bitching all morning
about the dirty forks and frankly
starting to get on my nerves I took two
forks from my desk which I used to some
food a couple days ago and now it's all
like oh it's unsanitary oh I'm gonna die
from need from the dirty fork that's
been sitting on the floor in your desk
the last couple weeks what are you doing
there I'm actually just kind of testing
the water here soup is ready to love why
don't you why don't you stick your your
face in there
it was incredibly smoky out here right
now very easy to read
look at the window it's like the world's
coming to an end
you
we're returning the airstream to its
rightful home is where he lives pretty
good time and this in this guy road
pretty well I feel pretty well rested
from my night's sleep all in all I feel
like I'm going to give it a six out of
10 I I think I concur with your
asportation of six attica you know it
has a lot of luxury to it it has some
things that they kind of missed but a
good amount of polish but overall you
know speakers in the front speakers in
the back pretty good sound system
reasonably good sound system really
smooth rides like a dream cruise control
and ice had it up to about 90 miles an
hour the fastest which was pretty good
in it it cruises pretty well for a bowl
like this fantastic so I you know I'm
gonna give it a six out of ten I'm going
to sign out thanks so much for tuning in
thank you soon thank you